that's really great I just the last  point is that we we spoke with Donna  Dubinsky last week and she's also in  alamo VL and in branford college I  believe and she was saying that she I  was asking her why she decided to donate  to Yale and why it was important to her  and she said that you know it's  important because she almost 0 something  back to you because they supported her  and she was you know gained a lot and  she is where she is today because of you  know so i think that's interesting and  empowering Yale women in order to to  give back to you and also build up the  experiences of opportunities for young  woman today I mean I think I think that  is part of the core of how we feel is  that we were privileged to be here and  we owe society for that privilege and  and that's part of where the impetus for  giving that comes